hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender the
nine pages okay this is a game that was
released recently in the slender legend
and I have no idea what is about other
than there are nine pages instead of an
eight it's not an official sequel to
Thunder the eight pages by mister parsec
productions huh know what that was
freaky though anyway so let's get right
into it not always did
I guess survival mode it is I have no
other thing to do and my god you got to
be kidding me
my mouse is once again outside of the
game good god I hate it when that
happens at games and what I mean by that
if I scroll too far to the left or right
my mouse pops out of the game so I just
got to make sure that I don't click
outside or else it will all tap that in
games it's just a small thing but it's
important for people with dual monitors
like me it's just an added thing of
difficulty okay so anyway I'm assuming
this is gonna be very slender like in
that there's gonna be slender in it very
saw that painting of them oh that's me
oh okay I thought there was like gonna
be oh hello I can move these boxes it's
made on the unity engine by the way same
as most of the other slender games uh-oh
physics paste boxes usually everything
in these games are just static object
it's so a magic got best slender game
ever alright let's try this good
even the arrival didn't that
physics-based to anything just kind of
curious what I'm looking for I mean I
know I'm looking for pages oh good at
least I can use things with E and I
don't have to click that means I don't
have to worry about the mouse being
outside the gate he'll anybody know
pages haven't found anything yet I mean
if there are nine and I haven't found
anything that means I might be here for
a while it's printing
what's up with you boxes damn physics
boxes duh anything under there secrets
nope nothing okay carrying on I
obviously don't know the layout of the
map or anything like that so I have no
idea what I'm looking for a why I'm
looking for it or what I'm doing hey
it's my slanty buddy again good for him
he's so haha he has no eyes yes this is
very true ah well that was a bit soon
don't you think Jesus Lundy gimme give
me a chance
holy balls f off okay hi ah good god
what am i doing and not fair that fair
he's moving he's a sly D he's a slippery
devil turn around in a circle if I spin
around three times and click my heels
find out Jana are you good
go to hell go to hell you fast go to
hell
uh-huh no no how I was able to slip by
him but I did good God go away
uh-huh ain't hurt Oh I want Paige I
can't hide
let me I'm trying to hide it seems to be
following me everywhere I go so I don't
really have a chance to hide that guy
he's an a-hole let's go
Capital a whole two pages in close
proximity good cuz otherwise I will be
screwed for life so quite a few rooms in
here Hey look that's a key why do I have
a key
hi there key what's with these cabinets
there better not be anything in these
cabinets till I may not be able to open
all oh where is he oh where is he I
don't want to know I don't wanna know
oh god it's like a maze in here Oh balls
Paige was dis why they're just the same
painting of Sunday man I mean there are
more there are other pages or paintings
oh god it's like a freak
haha I couldn't close the dark owner fat
was because I got the key he will eat
you well that doesn't seem very slender
like he will
Oh God Oh Oh God ha ha I was ready for
that 100 okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay hey you weren't there before
Oh Oh God
that wasn't right oh that wasn't right
what the hell happened
how did he get me how did he get me
I don't know it's hi again say I can't
make a video too short I'd just be silly
Oh God that was like horrible how is it
oh so bad oh man I don't ride I do not
feel good hey way this is close to where
I was I need a key I know where the key
is but why why would I want it that's
probably the ninth page god damn it
Oh balls how is so bad okay all right
voter oh good yeah it looks like the
pages are in the same places oh man this
game this game I tells ya I tells ya
it's not good man okay maybe then on the
same pieces because there wasn't one
there before but there is not one now
holy balls key is not there either
oh yeah where is yeah where is you at
where is your ad don't be a douche don't
tell her I know I refused
I must maybe I should have waited for
that door last because it seemed like
that was its to death I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the door last Oh light save me
save me light save me oh come on I need
nine Pilon oh don't look at so that's
what I was supposed to do is let's get
the one in the key room last and then
sprint to the door both sigh okay if I
look this way and then run banjo oh my
god that worked I can't believe that
worked
holy balls why did that work why is it
such a frigging maze in here aah aah oh
god it's August the worst maze ever
who's not happy fun times I did not
expect this particular slender game to
be this scary I'm alone I am were
certainly alone
[ __ ] oh come on
he's a bit annoyed ah oh
go stop it game gotta stop it man how's
it [ __ ] I want to play I hate my
chosen profession
okay just need to be careful not to go
in a circle again because okay that's
where I started I go right here I can
hit some other pages before I do back
around the hallway if I go to the end of
the hall wait here then loop back maybe
I'll be a little better I don't want to
go home cuddle under a blanket or
something huh it's not how what I had in
mind when I fired this game up okay
there's the key okay yeah I give me the
key
by guy move flowers like a ticket love
it I hate the way this one slides oh
this is in a bad place bhai night oh ah
oh man oh [ __ ] okay I just got it oh my
god
[ __ ] Jesus Christ no I wanna marvel at
the physics-based boxes again that was
more Oh more better than what is
happening now come on open up
aha he will carry you I don't know what
that said eat you probably oh girl I'm
abusing this spread fund I should not be
sprinting this much I should not be
sprinting this much okay I think I got
all the pages here I can go out in the
hallway again school yes okay it's okay
okay just go in here and then go in
there you're almost out of pages Oh God
okay so that's all the way I came in I
think I think maybe maybe I don't know
where Sonny he's not here anymore you
was here like her murder
oh yeah I came in here don't go that way
I leave it see him I did not even see
him I don't know him oh come on oh good
there's a face back here ha ha you can't
hide I can't my knees physics-based
boxes ok that's seven if I just need to
find one more and then open the door get
on the floor everybody do the diner
store and then I can go home and die in
a fire ah ah the last one before the
page in the locked room I think it'd get
through here through a series of no I
cannot I cannot oh god just go just go
go go go go
heartbeat II I just need the one in the
door and then I go out a narrow end
don't kill me I'm too young to die
oh okay save my friend for what I leave
the room with the locked page in it ah
no no no no gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme out there leave this place I
think I'm out I'm gone I'm so gone going
I'm leaving go don't kill me don't kill
me breath Ebru do kill me bro
Kangnam okay that was probably the
scariest letter game I've ever played in
my life I'm not exaggerating I have
never been more scared playing any game
than that game okay so anyway get ready
for another game titled scariest game
ever I know I've got a few but each one
takes big time I want to go home and cry
crying my bed while hugging a teddy bear
so try it for yourself link is in the
description below thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
don't mind me carrying my arm
glass jar you